[Music]
now Crazy's okay so the story of the
crazies is one that you've seen a
zillion times before an epidemic is
infecting the inhabitants of a small
Stephen King type town turning them all
into aggressive living zombies all 28
days later stylin [ __ ] and a few
survivors are on a quest to get out that
being said I really enjoyed it maybe it
was because I went into the crazies
fresh out of cop-out but even though I
thought the crazies was a bit unoriginal
I thought it was executed really well
the movie follows Timothy only found a
few others who were trying to escape
their town that's being overrun by
zombies and if the Walking Dead who
aren't really dead don't kill him the
guys with automatics and gas masks will
now the trailer had this whole Hills
Have Eyes vibe to it so I really wasn't
looking forward to the movie but the
movie really wasn't like that it was a
zombie movie
now the crazies wasn't the most
action-packed of zombie movies out there
but it did a really good job at making
you feel confined and trapped in a town
full of people who just want to rip you
apart and you need to get out past the
zombies and pass the fully armed
military yeah there are a lot of things
trying to kill him in this movie and
this movie definitely pulls off those
sweet-ass intense scenes you know those
scenes where you just feel helpless and
doomed why was it when a movie can pull
that off but I was not a fan of the
whole final destination car wash saying
it's like the movie went from cool
zombie movie to teen scream flick for
about five minutes
well once that scene was done it moves
on and it's all good and it was really
cool to see tensions rise within the
group it's like sometimes you don't know
if people in the group are infected or
they're just losing their mind so the
whole Lord of the Flies no rules no
consequences effect maybe they're just
intense because it's stressful now I'm a
big zombie movie fan I've made no
attempt to hide it and in that we zombie
fans know that there are rules when
dealing with pathogens that turn people
into the Walking Dead a big one is that
you don't let their blood saliva or DNA
get on you in any case whatsoever
especially not in an open wound and in
that there is a case in this movie where
someone should have been infected but
they weren't which means they're
carrying the antibodies to the zombie
apocalypse virus in which cases some
zombie apocalypse Messiah or it's just a
flaw in the writing probably the second
one but that's just nitpicker II know it
seems Timothy Olyphant caught on to what
was happening to the town relatively
fast which you could chalk that up to
the movie feeling rushed or maybe he's
just the smartest guy to hit the zombie
movie scene well give him credit and say
it's the second one another thing I
liked is that the crazy people that mean
they were kind of stupid but they could
still wield weapons I mean that's a cool
little variable right there you don't
see that often
zombies wielding guns yeah there goes
our
so if I had to compare it to something
imagine epitaphs one meets Dead Rising
meets 28 days later meets outbreak if
you like the majority of those you'll
probably like this movie I mean it's not
something you haven't seen before but if
you're a zombie fan I think you'll like
it
however if you like what you've seen
here and you're feeling bored or
adventurous and click on the link in the
sidebar to see more and maybe even
subscribe until next time